thank you you sort of disdain the folks
who are not actually using the social
media they're talking about their ROI on
well what if your decision makers or
your consumers aren't make aren't using
that social media well then you
shouldn't be there but my belief is that
that is not true I do not believe
there's that weird between Facebook from
an from an age standpoint and LinkedIn
from a b2b standpoint I do not believe
that you know outside of here's a good
one I helped a nursing home as of
because it was a friend of a friend not
for vaynermedia not for me not for a
case study just a couple pieces of
advice they're like listen our clients
are 82 you know 90 years old right I'm
like they're not their kids are your
actual client there's plenty of 40 50
and 60 year olds on Facebook and when
they started making content for them
they started converting and so here's
another one if you look at the dynamics
here's why I like snapchat vine and
Instagram to sell to 40 year old women
even though they're not there if you
look at the data right now 40 to 50 year
old women that have daughters that are
between the age of 8 and 16 the 8 to 16
year old is affecting their mother's
buying habits so much more than 10 or 20
years ago where it was the other way
around
because we're living through the youth
of vacation of our society if you look
at the habits the way they dress the way
they act what they do day in and day out
the average 45 year old woman today is
acting more similar to a 27 year old
woman only 20 years ago that if you sit
right now men and female and you think
about what your parent looked like when
they were your age right this minute you
know I mean people thought they were
done only two or three generations ago
at 50 60 70 right now we're so lucky
we're living longer we're taking better
care of ourselves and we're living
through this massive Uthoff occation
right that you know the Cougar movement
that was so fun to make jokes about is a
very real thing and so I we listen we
have dog we have other brands we're
marketing to 15 year old girls to make
their mom
by something because if their daughter
thinks it's cool their mom will buy in
so I don't know what you do so legal
service is a great example of being in
the content business so let me explain
well go with you on this legal services
I'm going to give you an example of
Guinness beer Guinness beer had a
problem about 60 years ago they had pub
sales decline in the UK for the first
time ever and they're like what are we
going to do they went and did old school
market research and surveyed people in
bars and they found out the two biggest
things that people talked about where
soccer and trivia so they created the
Guinness Book of World Records so I
don't know how many of you know that I
didn't know this until even a year ago
I'm just curious how many people had no
idea that Guinness beer started Guinness
Book of World Records so what they did
was they started a media company to
solve their problem I would tell you in
legal services that if you're if you're
focused on a certain genre that in this
book and I spend a little time on it
it's a whole nother book and genre I
believe I'm gonna make a pretty big
statement that I want everybody to wrap
their head around I believe every person
in this room right now and the
organizations that you're involved in
whether business-wise NGO or whatever
you do every one of you and it are in
the media business I now believe that
you're in the media business comma legal
services I'm in the media business comma
agency comma wine it's why I started my
wine show so I actually think what you
need to seriously consider in this world
is to become a media company meaning put
out content long-form around not
necessarily legal but the kind of things
that interests the people that you're
trying to court and then in a
buzzfeed.com way where you have no ads
but every fifth post is just is an
eighth of the ad think of it as
advertorial 2.0 think about you this is
very rogue so I know it's gonna be tough
to digest but I want to pitch you
something think about you starting a
golf website right literally covering
golf competing against Golf Digest and
that every 7th post was promoting your
business I actually believe that that is
going to be a blueprint of people doing
business
that they're going to start creating
media and content around the interest of
the target that they're trying to
recruit for their business over here to
the left Oakland and I know it's not
filled but I can see you know it's it's
it's listen I just want to stick on this
because it's such a big point and I
think it's the next decade the thought
that we have to be in the media business
because the cost of entry is zero and
not truly zero but in comparison to
starting Golf Digest or the golf Network
by putting a golf daily.com on WordPress
and then producing micro content to
drive traffic the cost of entry is so
low thus getting those youth so it gets
it's a very interesting thing I've been
testing it it's remarkable we're
launching our first ever we have a
cracker and we're launching the leading
cheese review site of the internet in
March and we're going to be by building
that it's going to be a gateway to the
cracker and we don't necessarily want
them to match the cracker in the cheese
it's just that we want to elevate the
brand equity of the cracker and like
doing it with high-end cheese it will do
that for us but that's the kind of stuff
and that's only the media instead of
buying banner ads on the media